[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof hello walter hello martin
how are you today i'm very well and you
i'm okay
it's time to discuss what's happening in
the world again right yes
like always things are happening so fast
we can barely keep up with it exactly
and then we think all right we're going
to do this but we never get to what we
really want to do because we always have
to do something else right else pops up
yes
let's open with a word of prayer and
then we can have this discussion
hi heavenly father thank you so much
again
for giving us the opportunity to discuss
important matters we ask that you bless
us and give us the holy spirit to
enlighten our minds in jesus name amen
amen
now martin we're going to discuss the
great reset and the road to cop 26.
and i'm always amazed
that there are
people in the world
that
do not see any trend
in any direction whatsoever these are
just purely coincidental events
that happen to be crystallizing
universally in every nation yes
and it just happens to come together and
everything is just
pure chance
i also stand amazed don't you stand
amazed
and if somebody says but excuse me
there is a pattern here
and there must be
someone that is
organizing the pattern
then immediately you are branded with
all kinds of names and what have you
conspiracies yes so
i don't know
are people blind or what is their
problem can you help me
i think the devil keeps you blind
but there's nobody as blind as those
that will not say will not see
yeah so you can see through this
if you want to
and
what also is fascinating to me
is
that there seems to be this effort to
arrange the thinking of humanity in a
unidirectional way
and anything
that questions or even dares to question
the agenda or
the road ahead
is
immediately ostracized by
society yes austin said
you have to go in this direction it's
the only one that's possible no matter
how many brilliant minds there are
no matter how many cabinet members there
are how many politicians how many
presidents or whatever
if this is the agenda
and there's one man playing the tune
everybody goes along even if there are
500 that say that it's wrong
it doesn't change
so
who is pulling the string and
why are they pulling this string it's
interesting i mean if you just look at
the title and you
these days if you use the word the great
reset
you already
media has already put you in a brand of
conspiracy theorist yes but they talk
about it themselves all the time
but nobody is allowed to question it
or cop 26
it is on the agenda everybody is hyped
up
and organizing the biggest names amongst
humanity and that's where
the crux lies yes who's part of
taking part of this and and how do they
get everybody to participate and sing
the tune
whether it is somebody from the media
whether it is someone from the
entertainment world whether it's someone
from the political world whether it's
someone from the religious world it
doesn't matter they all have the same
instrument and they play the same tune
correct
now
this to me is absolutely
astounding
and then we have
this beautiful book
and everybody
is on a bandwagon now i read a book
i i will not even mention the name
it is
a terribly long book
and it has all of these details in them
but when it comes to the god of the
bible
there is so much animosity
and so much hatred
that
comes through
that you are astounded that these people
have so much knowledge
and they put everything into such
perspectives but when it comes to the
bible
they have absolutely
zero understanding of the typology
they only see
what has happened and god gets the blame
for everything
but in actual fact
god is the one
that says why are you in this mess
i'm not going to take you out of the
mess because you have to learn some
lessons as to
what sin actually produces and causes
so i'm going to play this game within
the parameters that you are living in
and then when the time is up
then i will
get rid of that system
so here is god is love
and here is reality at the moment
and the two seem so far removed
and the one is called the hope and the
future
and the other one is called the present
reality now unfortunately
we are living in a present reality
so let's talk about the present reality
so that we can eventually come to the
hope correct
let's do it and that's important we're
going to try in this
discussion
to put the puzzle again together because
there's a link of all of this to a
certain agenda now as we've discussed
before suicides are going up in the
world
at the horrendous rate so obviously
people are not comfortable or are not
willing to continue even
living in the circumstances that the
world is providing
and and
it must be terrible if you want to plan
a future
in in a world of such uncertainty and
that is why it is so important that we
have a hope
great because if you didn't have a hope
you wouldn't have an anchor nothing
you would be drifting in the sea of
inconsistency
of
nonsensical
rules and regulations
absolute total restriction
of personal freedom
i mean is there such a thing left such
as personal freedom
or is it encroaching into your very
rooms within your own dwelling
definitely everything you're not allowed
to be you're not allowed to do this
you're not allowed to do that you're not
allowed to say what you think
nothing and somebody will climb on the
bandwagon but let's not have so long
introductions that we don't get to the
topic so basically
what
has happened now is we're just going to
go
through the timelines as to exactly what
is happening and then discuss them
correct here is an article in life site
and it comes from february 2021
secretive international banking group
may enforce great reset
green agenda on the world
now already just the headline
why would something have to be so
secretive
if there is a real problem
then let's address it
and let the scientific debate or the
religious debate or political debate
continue right but no everything is done
behind the scenes and already jesus said
i have done
nothing in secret
so they want to enforce the great
green
reset
agenda us federal reserve has recently
joined a little-known international
conglomerate of central banks all
fundamentally committed
to enforcing the green eco-friendly
dictates of the anti-life
global governance paris agreement in
line with the great reset
such a move has raised alarming concerns
about the influence which banks will
exert in enforcing green policies as
part
of the world economic forum's so-called
great reset just the terminology
tells you that people are uncomfortable
because they don't know what's going on
behind the scenes
do you agree yes
in december 2020 the u.s federal reserve
board announced that it had joined the
network of central banks and supervisors
for greening the financial system
which is an international group of
central banks and supervisors with the
purpose of transforming the global
economy
in alignment with green sustainable
policies
the member banks are some of the most
influential in the world with national
and international names such as bank of
canada bank of england
bank de france dubai financial services
authority
european central bank japan's bank
people banks of china swiss national
bank u.s federal reserve i mean those
are the big names
now martin if you're going to do a great
green reset
that means everything non-green
goes
that's basically life as you knew it
right
totally different from what we know at
this stage absolute
change
so
either you
switch over into a totally new economy
or you sink
so if you are in the petroleum world
yeah then you are in trouble right yes
uh if you are in the alternative energy
industry you might have a way forward
yes
but how much of the world economy is
just going to
fresh crash
it's interesting with this cold winter
that we had in a warming world
that germany had to revert back to oil
in order to
heat the houses and keep everything
going
because
the alternative energy didn't work i
mean we discussed that last time
and just another interesting thing is
for any skeptics
look at the names of these banks that
sit around the table with the world
economic forum and discuss these things
so the world economic forum
is a voice to be reckoned with
and it is also linked to the religious
world correct
and this is where we are always
uh very interested in our ears prick up
when we see the link between the
religious world
and
this
secular world
in actual fact martin
if you were a church
a christian church
what would be your commission
go ye into yeah the whole world and do
what
spread the gospel
correct tell them of the good news just
one question
do you hear anything from the churches
in that direction no no no you just hear
about we have to
save the earth and we have to save the
earth all right but the bible says the
earth is going to wear out like a
garment and the inhabitants die like
flies that's what it says right
and it tells us that there will be total
destruction of life
it tells us that the animals will
disappear now i've heard
that they have a plan for a progression
in order to implement their great
reset and
many many economists have spoken about
this and some of them are quite adamant
that there will be an economic crash
well obviously if you're going to
dump
60 70 percent of the world's economy
into the ocean in a great reset like
this
there will be an economic crash right
yeah so a recession such as the world
has never
seen that's quite tumultuous does the
bible say
that the merchants of the world will
wail
and that the gold and the silver is
cankered
in other words becomes
useless so
there will be an economic crash
now
we're not going to be predictive in
terms of timelines some economists are
saying
by the middle of 2021
some are saying well at the latest
november december
2021 but that's actually irrelevant the
point is it's going to come i mean
i'm sure if i remember correctly we
showed some of this
they've been talking about this for
quite quite some time absolutely because
the yield curve has inverted already
long i think almost two years ago
correct so and that is an indication of
a recession looming and then we looked
at graphs
we looked at for example
well any aspect if you look at
flu seasons for example
the graphs
have a peak and a decline
a peak in a valley a peak in a valley
and if you
make your decisions in the valley
then that is the worst case scenario
then you if you make your peak your
decision
making criteria then that's also a worst
case scenario so either this way or that
way
you can always preach
calamity is coming and the economic
world has also had this kind of wave
throughout history and there's no reason
why it won't continue
so the last sentence here is
meanwhile amongst the observer banks on
names such as the bank of international
settlement
european investment bank international
monetary fund world bank and
international finance corporation
and these are the great bailout banks
yes
the ones that
help
the countries in debt so they're going
to stand there and
become the heroes
martin who's your hero
when it comes to
a total collapse of what we understand
my hero is jesus
because he says he will be the savior
taking you away from all this nonsense
correct
but the secular world
says
no we cannot allow the divine foot and
the door
we
will say how it will happen
so the plan is
number one we will have this pandemic
and that is the opportunity for a great
reset
then we will have an economic crash
and that economic crash will just tell
us that the world will have to be reset
in a different direction
and whatever remains after that goes in
the new direction
and then we need a climate agenda
because otherwise it wouldn't be green
right correct
so then we'll go into a climate agenda
with the climate lockdowns and the
climate
issues that have to be resolved
supposedly
because their models show that this is
so even though there are models that
show the country which are ignored
and then they are actually talking about
a
biodiversity crash
so explain that to us
all right what is the biodiversity crash
a biodiversity crash is when all of a
sudden
species
that have existed for
millennia
will start disappearing
and this will be
used to say
that there needs to be this drastic
realignment and reset
because the planet is now in such a
state that even the animals are
suffering and as a consequence we need
to give nature more space
we have to move people into
specific locations
which are the cities of the future
that will be prepared for this kind of
thing
and there will have to be a huge
infrastructure change
and a lot of money will have to go into
infrastructure
so that we can make these changes to
give nature space we have to green
nature again
so there where humanity was humanity
will have to go they will have to be
herded into
spaces that are prepared for this
calamity and the
biodiversity crash
will be used
to
make sure that these things happen
now
martin
does the bible say anything about a
decline in biodiversity
yes
yes the book of revelation
and by the way
before
you get the plagues
you have the decline
in in the environment and a third and a
third and a third of all the animals
died and a third of this and the third
of that and the third of that right in
the book of revelation and then in the
plagues how much dies
oh
is that a biodiversity crash that's a
nightmare yeah a biodiversity nightmare
all right so
if you were
let's speculate
if you were as
a student of scripture
even in a contrary way
let's say you were
the devil
would you know that there is a
biodiversity crash coming yes
you would know right
because even the devils believe in
tremble says the bible yes
but that doesn't mean they have faith
right
okay so they believe but they don't have
faith
so he's he knows there's a biodiversity
crash coming can he use this information
to tell humanity look what's going to
happen and it's as a consequence of this
that that and the other and therefore we
must do this that in the other exactly
is it possible yes i think that's
exactly i was going to point out
and
just for interest sake
i have in my life as you know
made quite a study of
this
luciferian world
and before i became a christian i was
actually
quite
steeped in that kind of world
and it always surprised me if you take a
book like
albert pike
morals and dogma
which is basically
the prescribed book for freemasonry
it's based on the bible yeah
but it is contrary to the bible twisted
version it's a twisted version it's a
luciferian version
if you take blavatsky's writings
based on the bible yes everything is
about the bible but everything is
twisted round
and reversed right
and
morals and dogma for example when you
take the chronology
which chronology are they using the
biblical
chronology
and and which of the bibles are they
using for their chronology
they're using
the received text they're using the
received text king james that that is
that is um to me amazing
so their dates
i know mundi
since creation
are absolutely in line with what the
bible has to say
and these people are contrary to god
in fact they despise everything that is
god and make god evil
and evil good and the bible says woe to
those
that do that right so
he's a student of scripture because he
knows where the world is going
and uh let's not get too deeply into
this or else we won't
be able to finish what we have to decide
yet but
basically
all the major banks are saying
we're going to have a great reset
if you're going to have a great reset
then you must have a great economic
realignment yes which means
millions of people
will be affected
now martin for our skeptical friends out
there
in
all the various societies including the
religious world
uh
do you think there is a planned agenda
so that everybody gets onto the same
page
i am sure it is yeah sure it is
especially when you look well it's easy
to find out it's easy to find out well
let's look at this little video over
here
and
they use a specific term and that is
martin
built back better build
back
better which is
a great reset
of criminology what does it mean to
build back
if you bolt back it means that something
that is gone has to be
put in place so in if you want to build
back
then something must have been removed
that has to be built back yeah you have
to and then improve
yes
and you have to do it better
so the very terminology build back
better
tells you
that the old is going to be eradicated
and the new is going to be built and
it's going to cost a fortune exactly
but the little man in the street
will have to go and sit behind these
little bars being surveyed by his little
computer environment to make sure that
he stays within the parameters permitted
and i i can see these people maneuvering
themselves into positions to try and
overcome what has already been predicted
will happen
they will not succeed no no
so let's have a look
build back better to build back better
or whatever and build back better to
build back better build back from this
uh global pandemic build back better
build back better building back better
to build back better build it back
better and build it back better build
back better to build back build back
better it's about building this country
back
better build back better
building back better build
back
better some would say to build back back
better we would say to really have
agrees on great research
i don't know did they all copy each
other or do they have a common
instructor
it sounds like a common instructor and
just to sum it up and the chief behind
the scenes here just says well this is
what it means it means a great reset
correct
and how many economic casualties will
there be
when you remove what there was before
lots unbelievable right okay the world
econom economy as you know it will be
gone we'll be gone all right
and the next question i then have
who's going to build back better the
ones that lost everything now or someone
else
someone else
yes
someone else is going to go back better
and does that someone else
have your personal interests at heart
no
you must remember
they're doing it for the common good
because this is the
big phrase that's being used okay and
that's the glue with the religious part
oh correct and of course we've already
defined who determines what the common
good is
obviously the one who
branded that terminology the most right
all right let's have a look at what this
really means and what did klaus schwab
actually mean when he said this
reset will lead to the fusion of our
physical digital and biological identity
martin
i want you to
to mull over that sentence
it will lead to the fusion of our
physical digital and biological identity
would you like your biological identity
to be reset and fused with a digital
uh component it sounds like you're
becoming a robot
so the founder of the world economic
forum glass schwab recently said that
the fourth industrial revolution as part
of the great reset will lead to a fusion
of our physical digital and biological
identity this transhumanist approach of
the elites has always been dismissed by
the public as a conspiracy theory
in his book shaping the future of the
fourth industrial revolution he writes
that implantable microchips could be
used for example
to read people's thoughts
now
i think god made thoughts
secret for a person purpose
right definitely
i think many people
in the world would feel extremely
uncomfortable
if they could read the next man's
thoughts yeah
don't you think so exactly especially if
you are in a high-powered meeting where
the stakes are high and everybody is
clamoring for the top position
yeah that could be fun
or let's take it on a personal level
if everybody knew what the next one was
thinking about his neighbor
and the reality it didn't conform to the
smile on the face yes
that could be a problem right
so what god has made secret
should be well left alone what's between
you and god
they want to open the open correct they
want it out in the open well you know
the catholic church has always said we
need a confessional
so whatever you do just tell me about it
but we know that secret sins should be
confessed to god alone yeah it's got
nothing to do with anyone else even that
part is a little bit skewed in the
modern translations that says you have
to
confess you confess your sins to your
brother yes correct yeah your faults
there's a big difference between faults
actual actual the word is false
so even crossing a national border could
one day require a detailed brain scan to
assess a person's safety risk
in fact some of us already have the
feeling that our smartphones have become
an extension of ourselves today's
external devices
from portable computers to virtually
reality headsets are almost certainly
implanted in our body and brain writes
schwab
so what he's saying is now you have this
gadget in your hand
but very soon
you will have it implanted it can be in
your head we've already had those phones
where you can
type on your arm
where you don't need a touchpad you just
use your arm
so
this is amazing and this is so contrary
to the word of god
now
god can read the mind
but he deemed it fit
to
take this capacity away
and satan has been toying with us for
decades that's why
he wants to have
this possibility that i can read your
mind and he's had his clairvoyance
and his mind readers and they supposedly
tell you this that and the other
and god calls that kind of thing an
abomination
yes
to try and
predict the future all these things
correct
so basically you won't be able to even
move
in this kind of world
you'll be so regulated
so
will they regulate the way in which you
travel
yeah definitely let's say you want to go
somewhere and they say but this is not
with within the parameters that are
permissible in our new society
you want to go to nature no you would be
disturbing nature
so they will give you a car that drives
itself
will you have your own car in the future
how will this work let's just have a
look
the biggest application is the
autonomous driving this is going to
replace the entire transportation
that we have we're used to today you
will no longer buy cars
but imagine there is uber that gets here
in 30 seconds and it's very reliable
very clean and there's no nasty driver
because there is no driver
and it's very safe
would you not not buy a car
one thing about ai is it gets better
with data in 10 years after its first
launch it will probably be so much
better than people most of us will be
afraid to drive you know why because
autonomous vehicles will start talking
to each other
they will miss each other by one
centimeter and we as humans are will
become our worst enemies because we're
going to be the threat to our lives the
machines are going to be safe and pretty
soon after that humans will be
disallowed from driving having
downloaded an app you swipe into the
store cameras and sensors monitor your
choices with no barcode scanning you
just fill your bag and walk out
this is all about high-tech surveillance
technology but even so i still feel a
bit like a shoplifter we've all heard
about the impact of no frills
supermarkets in the uk but what about
this
no tills
some privacy campaigners expressed
concerns about the technology but to
many in this industry it's just the next
logical step in 1948 co-op brought the
uk its first self-service supermarket
nowadays grocers including sainsbury's
and tesco have shopping apps so
customers sidestep tills the shop
workers union is worried about jobs
so it seems that life will be
very regulated
you don't need any more personnel
everything can be
digital
it would be
a whole new world
and if this
forms part of the great reset
then obviously this
there will have to be a lot of
infrastructure
that gets updated for those cars yes
these digital type of
technology using uh stores
and also like they said in the last part
of the video
that workers unions are worried
because there will be unemployment
because of these
types of
technology advancements yes now modern
if you're going to
like the georgia geyserstones say reduce
the population in any case
then perhaps this is
why you can use a system like this but
the interesting thing to me was
that you will not drive and you will be
scared to drive because you are actually
a danger to others the digital world can
do it better
so i wonder whether they're going to fit
camels and horses with
with self-driving devices as well
because
you're not you won't be in control of
your life you can't make a decision that
you're going to go
here there or the other
because that vehicle is programmed to
take you to a specific place and
anything that is deemed out of the
bounds
will be impossible to go to it's also
pushing a lot the
view of the common good
that you will be scared to do anything
that's not for the common good exactly
and that and
to a large extent they're using that in
the medical world today or exactly
everyone's saying if you do not do this
and if you do not conform to this
standard you're actually a danger to
society yes sir martin we've seen that
they're saying there will be an economic
crash
they're talking about a
total
reset
of everything and to build back better
and then you must have certain dangers
in the world that you have to guard
against and we've spoken about the
climate one we'll come more
to that in a little bit later
then you also have the danger of cyber
attacks so let's just refresh our
memories as to what klaus schwab had to
say on that issue
we all know
but still
pay insufficient attention to the
frightening scenario
of a comprehensive cyber attack
which would bring
to a complete heart
to the power supply
transportation hospital services our
society as a whole
the cobai 19 crisis
would be seen in this respect as a small
disturbance
in comparison
to a major cyber attack
to use the kobe 19 crisis
as a timely opportunity
to reflect
on the lessons cyber security community
can draw
and improve our in preparedness
for a potential cyber pandemic
so martin
the covet crisis was an opportunity
do you think a cyber crisis could be an
opportunity
definitely definitely
and then you could show that the old
technology is subject to this terrible
possibility
and the only thing to do with it is to
scrap it scrap it let's go to something
else right yeah
so we get we suddenly in our lifetime
are seeing
not these calamities but these
tremendous opportunities
now tell me
are there opportunities for you
no
there must be opportunities for someone
else right
correct but definitely not for you and
definitely not for me because my car
will be gone i will have no control
anymore
my systems will be out
and somebody will have an opportunity
who will that somebody be
now just for interest sake
when we last discussed
the events leading up to
the pandemic
we saw that there were many exercises
where they practiced basically
the worst case scenario
and
introduced a world plan to deal with it
a blueprint a blueprint
and the world has been basically
following the script right correct
so
are there any such
planned
exercises to deal with this great cyber
attack that were coming
and the answer of course is yes
so here the world economic forum is
planning one of these exercises and they
call it the cyber
polygon this project is part of the
world economics forum's center for cyber
security platform
so what is a cyber polygon
cyber polygon is a unique cyber security
event that combines the world's largest
technical training exercise for
corporate teams and an online conference
featuring
senior officials from international
organizations and leading corporations
the 2021 technical exercise builds and
tests the skills needed to protect our
industries
centering on a targeted supply chain
attack
the event will be held online on july
the 9th of 2021 right correct
so here is an
again
an exercise which will create a
blueprint for a possible future
event and it is attended
or the players
are from
corporations
so they are not the ones
that
will be
destroyed by such an attack
everybody else will and to them it will
be an
opportunity correct an opportunity to
change things and they've already
discussed this whole thing at the davos
meeting
earlier this year correct so this is
this is taking place at a very high
level
so martin at that davos
agenda basically they discussed some of
these issues let's look at what they
discussed this comes from the world
economic forum youtube channel
and this is what it was about
the kobit 19 pandemic has shaken our
economies and societies to the core and
shown us how vulnerable we are to
biological threats
in the digital world similar risks are
being overlooked right now a cyber
attack with covert-like characteristics
would spread faster and further than any
biological virus
its reproductive rate would be around 10
times greater than what we've
experienced with the coronavirus to give
you an idea one of the fastest worms in
history the 2003 slammer sapphire one
doubled in size approximately every 8.5
seconds infecting over 75 000 devices in
10 minutes and almost 11 million devices
in 24 hours fortunately at least until
now cyber attacks have not impacted our
health the way pandemics have but the
economic damages and therefore the
impact they have had on our daily lives
have been equal and sometimes even
greater you see the only way to stop the
exponential propagation of a covert like
cyber threat is to fully disconnect the
millions of vulnerable devices from one
another and from the internet
all of this in a matter of days
a single day without the internet would
cost our economies more than 50 billion
us dollars and that's before considering
the economic and societal damages should
these devices be linked to essential
services such as transport or health
care as the digital realm increasingly
merges with our physical world the
ripple effects of cyber attacks on our
safety just keep on expanding at a
faster pace than what we're preparing
for
covert 19 was known as an anticipated
risk
so is the digital equivalent let's be
better prepared for that one the time is
now
i find it very interesting
that they always link everything back to
health
right yeah
and uh
as they're saying here is a possible
future event
now i just have a question
if they are already practicing this and
saying that the world has to be prepared
for this and what will be knocked out
as a consequence of this is this a
perhaps a means to bring about an
economic crash
we speculating
but if you go back
and you look at the track record it's
not very good
it shows that every time they've been
doing these type of things
it becomes a reality so we're not saying
anything we're just asking some
questions and the questions i think are
based on
what we've seen happening in reality
right
so it's not it's not uh i think an
unreasonable question no i don't think
it's that far-fetched to think this way
especially if you know that there is an
agenda
definitely
although many they're telling you they
they're saying to you that covet 19 was
an opportunity to
know how to to to handle this when it
comes so this might be the next
opportunity right
now let's link it together
here you have the catholic news agency
and says pope francis calls for global
covet 19 recovery plan
in message to the world bank and the
international monetary fund so is he
involved in that
circle yes absolutely he's speaking the
same language
so pope francis appealed for a global
coronavirus recovery plan in a message
to participants in the spring meeting
of the world bank and international
monetary fund the imf the pope's message
was entrusted to cardinal peter turkson
prefect of the vatican diecastry for
promoting integral human development
to be presented during the april 5 to 11
meetings of the international financial
institutions
do you find it interesting martin that
the cardinals
are there
at the international
monetary yes meetings the fina
financial meetings
so the pope repeated his call for the
cancellation of the debts of the poor
countries battling covert 19 which he
first made in his easter would be at
orbee address in 2020
so that is a great reset
settling all the debts
he argued that true development could
only be achieved through the pursuit of
universal common good so he's playing
that same instrument
with the same tune that tune is being
played
it follows that public money may never
be disjoint from the public good
and financial markets should be
underpinned by laws in regulations aimed
at ensuring that they truly work for the
common good
he said referring to his christmas
urbi et orbi message in which he called
for vaccines for all
threatened by covet 19 he said that the
poor should benefit from justly financed
vaccine solidarity
insisted that the law of the market
should not come before the law of love
and the health of all
interesting that everything is always
linked to the health message right
the three angels message are also linked
to the health message but it's a very
different health message
that's god's one and this is well
well maybe the enemy's one
martin that's a dangerous thing that you
just said
the enemy's one
now let's just get this straight there
are many things in the medical world
which are absolutely marvelous
and any
medical practitioner
of whatever level
or wherever engaged
should have this paramount urge to help
humanity
and in actual fact in order to do that
martin
you should always argue from cause to
effect correct now we're a little bit
off the topic here but
let's just run with this for a second
cause to effect
that
has been
totally eradicated by the pharmaceutical
world
and the bible talks about pharmacia
as part of
the activities of the beast in the last
as of the enemy i have i'm hearing this
all the time from the vatican
pharmacia is a witchcraft but in actual
fact of course it is the pharmacological
world asclepius and all of these things
and if you think about it
if you go to the doctor
you come with the symptoms
and for the symptoms there is a
prescription
and that prescription comes from
pharmaceut
comes from the pharmacological world so
you have these big pharmacological
companies and they have people that call
themselves reps
right they represent the company
they go to all the medical
institutions and individuals
and say if this is the symptoms this is
what we have prescribe this and many
cases there are perks involved yes in
order to prescribe this
so the whole medical world has moved in
the direction
of reacting to the symptoms
rather than the cause
god always wants to address the cause
the body is sick
there is a reason
now if you take the veterinary world
it's a very interesting world correct
because
if you have a a pig
that has symptoms
you're not going to put him through an
mri scan in order to find out what his
problem is
and where the problem is and then
prescribe the medication
because then the value of the pig will
have been exceeded by
the value of
the study in itself right
so very often
if there are certain symptoms
in the veterinary world
then immediately will they will say well
maybe it's a mineral shortage
maybe this
there's a magnesium shortage maybe
there's a calcium shortage maybe there's
a zinc
shortage
maybe there is
you know a minor element shortage let's
add this to the food and see ah the
problem is solved
and there was a very famous
nobel laureate who wrote a book dead
doctors don't lie
and he came from that veterinary
perspective and said you know
treat the symptoms
then you have what you have in the
medical world
you don't actually solve the problem
but treat the cause
and you can help humanity
so my problem with all of this
is that all of this is treating the
symptoms it never
treats the cause
if people are immune suppressed
well what could be the cause
could it be a dietary
maybe a deficiency in that deficiency
could it be something that you could
correct quite easily with lifestyle
and
this is the issue but they
have made technology yes
and pharmacia the answer to all the
problems
so the problem is it's not really the
medical world it's the pharmacological
world concluding his message he wrote
solutions for a more inclusive and
sustainable future a future where
finance is at the service of the common
good
where the vulnerable and the
marginalized are placed at the center
and where the earth our common home is
well cared for he's put everything into
that one sentence yes
he summed up the problem
and he is the master puppeteer
in that sentence the whole time it's
common good common good economy the
finance the health everything
and let's get it quite straight again
common good is a moral issue yes
and that moral issue has to be
determined by a moral entity which is of
course himself self
correct
but what if my moral compass
is directly opposed to his moral compass
then i have a problem right correct
because he who wields the sword
also dictates the tune
yes but i have news for him
i have another sword
and this sword is mightier than his
so common good requires that
we also have this common home and that
this has to be treated in a particular
way for the common good
so let's just recap what these people
are saying
um in the past when you're talking about
climate change you have said quote i
want you to panic
i want you to feel the fear i feel every
day
uh is there what what particular study
or scientific report
did you read that may
made you come to this conclusion
uh thank you for a question first of all
let me just clear that those are
metaphors
um in speeches you often use metaphors
of course i don't mean literally that i
want people to panic
uh
so
so there was no scientific study that
made me come to that conclusion
oh okay so you didn't say that
i did but it's a metaphor that you often
use in speeches metaphor for what
i mean how do you what i'm asking on
panic
i want you to panic what does that tell
me what you meant by that
by that i mean that i want people to
step out of their comfort zones
um yeah and to not just see the climate
crisis as a far distant threat but
rather as something that is impacting
people already today and
people to step out of their comfort
zones to start taking real action
let's have a listen to this she's the
new kid on the block pearl greta's gone
she's history she's ancient news she's
been and there's a new one zie bastida
she's uh the new 19 year old who's taken
them all by storm have a listen
the climate crisis is the result of
those perpetuating and upholding the
harmful systems of colonialism
oppression capitalism and
market-oriented greenwash solutions
we demand that you stop fossil fuel
investments and subsidies
we demand that you stop any new fossil
fuel infrastructure and existing fossil
fuel extraction including pipelines
we demand comprehensive non-eurocentric
and intersectional climate education
including literacy on climate justice
environmental racism ancestral and
indigenous wisdom on historical
movements
disability justice green careers and
sustainable living
james this is paul pott this is
terrifying this isn't even funny anymore
this is being backed in by the united
states secretary of state anthony blink
yes now this is being touted by joe
biden the green new deal also
importantly
recognizes the systemic cause of climate
change because while climate change is a
planetary crisis it is not
caused by an environmental or
random
it does not have a random or
environmental genesis
client the climate crisis is a crisis
born of injustice and it is a crisis
born of the pursuit of profit at any and
all human and ecological cost
which means
that we must recognize in legislation
that the trampling of indigenous rights
is a cause of climate change the the
trampling of racial justice is a cause
of climate change
modern
morality has been linked to climate
change
and it's amazing that it is papal
morality
that has been linked to climate change
and of course uh
i've already opined at one stage
that the we demand
what happened to
say is something
that we should be allergic to
and you asked what happened to the good
old we request yes what happened to the
good old we request or let's look at
this
in a logical light
so
this is uh
bringing in a lot of emotion
uh bringing in a lot of division
creating
elite groups and
other groups
and actually fermenting hatred amongst
humanitarian groups yes
and there's another problem
this is
what's being put out there in the media
right now
correct
so
if you
speak out against this
you become the enemy you are
automatically the enemy now i have a
question for you
uh
is sin bound by national boundaries no
are you sure
is sun bound by racial boundaries no
definitely not
everybody sins okay
is sin bound by
economic boundaries
no
sin is an international phenomenon right
and sin is in every race tribe creed
so
the catholic church
has categorized sin
the bible doesn't but the roman catholic
church has categorized it into venial
sins
and mortal sins
and the the pope has already said
that those who go against the climate
agenda are actually committing mortal
sins
so you have greater sins and you have
lesser sins
sin is sin the wages of
sin
is the death not the wages of mortal sin
because according to catholic theology
the wages of mortal sin is death
but the wages of venial sins is
purgatory
so you can
burn it off yes don't worry about it you
know
we don't have to be too concerned about
that sort of thing
but this is driving a wedge between
people and the bible says
in the final analysis
aetnos will be against aetnos
kingdom against kingdoms
so we will have nations
fighting nations let's say one nation
doesn't want to come on board whether
climate change
no
trouble yes
and atnos
what if you could pin
ethnically
everything that is wrong to an ethnic
group
right yes to a color then you could have
great turmoil exactly the bible says by
one blood
he created all
all
so we are actually all one this is a way
of bringing about the divide that the
bible says will be taking place
at the end of time matthew 24.
and this is a very dangerous game it is
this is a very dangerous game because it
ferments hatred
between specific groups
and then there are those that are
in the right echelon with the right
mindset according to them and those that
aren't
and you can already see the passion in
the faces
and the animosity in the faces
where is the god of love and tolerance
and kindness injustice there was that
one
portion where greta said that i want you
to become angry yes
that's not what the bible says no
so
i would just like to
reiterate that you know when it comes to
these
issues
let's recognize
the base problem
the base problem is sin
and sin leads to greed
and greed leads to
whatever it is that you see in the
environment
one person wanting to control everything
and that is a product of sin it's not a
product of race or creed or national
identity
it is common to all
humanity
and when you rise above it and the only
way to rise above it is to come out of
the slavery of sin and that is only
possible in christ
so instead of preaching this excuse me
nonsense
preach the gospel
amen so again martin you need the media
to come on board right
the media has to now tout this so that
the collective mindset can run in this
channel
and uh
don't you dare
think contrary to it because then you
are an enemy of the people
like our focus was to get trump out of
office right without saying that that's
what it was right so our next thing is
going to be for climate change awareness
what does that look like
i don't know i'm not sure i have a
feeling it's just going to be like
constantly showing
videos of like
decline and
ice and
weather warming up and like the effects
of having an economy and and really
the head of the network like just who's
that is that
zucker yeah i imagine that
he's got his counsel and they've all
like discussed like
where they think um
so that's like the next
pandemic
like story like that we'll yeah that
will
will be to death but that one's got
longevity
you know what i mean it's not like
there's a definitive ending to the
pandemic or you know like
it'll taper off to a point that it's you
know not a problem anymore probably
think it's gonna take years so
they'll probably be able to milk
mother earth is angry she's telling us
whether she's telling us with hurricanes
on the gulf coast fires in the west
whatever it is that the climate crisis
is real and has an impact there is
something so fundamental that also
cannot be denied and that is climate
change climate change and
those who do not believe it do so at
their own peril it's an ominous warning
that we have to act on climate
scientists have been warning for years
that climate change could create extreme
fire conditions such as this in
california alone this past august was
the warmest ever i worry that people are
not fully understanding the connection
between the changing climate climate
change human contribution to it and what
we're seeing happen in california the
debate is over around climate change
just come to the state of california
martin
did job experience climate change
yes
and noah as well no i had to make a
climate change that's for sure
but uh basically what we're what we're
trying to say here is
there's an agenda
definitely they absolutely admit
outright that they're going to play this
trumpet
you add the build back better
you've got the climate change
everybody the same tune
they're going to play this tune no
matter what and you better be on board
so let's bring
pope francis back into it because no
matter what the topic the man is
involved
but francis in earth day messages warns
we are at the edge on climate change the
man is everywhere maybe he should start
working for cnn
yeah
in twin earth day messages pope francis
warned the gathering of world leaders
and the global community at large that
we are at the edge with climate change
and the time to take action is now
the pope made appearances minutes apart
april 22nd during two virtual events
marking earth day
the international leader summit on
climate organized by us president joe
biden and the earth day live live stream
organized by earth day
network
both the global catastrophes
covet and climate change prove that we
do not have time to wait francis
said in a pre-recorded video for earth
day live
time urges us and as covet 19
demonstrated we do have the tools to
face the loss
we have the instruments this is the
moment to act we are at the edge
we need to ensure that the environment
is cleaner purer and that it is
conserved we must care for nature so
that nature may care for us francis said
later to the summit
then his final sentence
this is a
moral
imperative
that's what we said yeah
a moral imperative and he's elevated it
to the level of a mortal sin to go
contrary to it so if it's moral it's
almost salvational
absolutely
if it's a if it's a mortal sin it's
absolutely salvation
biden said a moment of peril but also a
moment of extraordinary possibilities
time is short but i believe we can do
this and i believe we will do this
ursula font layen president of the
european union added this will be the
make or break decade for our climate
other nations including japan and canada
also announced ramped up climate goals
referred to as
internationally determined contributions
while others like south korea south
africa and bangladesh said they intended
to submit new targets in the coming
months
and you even had president xi jinping
it said the globe's largest coal
consumer would strictly limit its coal
use in the next five years before
phasing it down
brazil was involved he previously was
not that interested in this he actually
started to go against
but he's come around right now he's come
around he said no they'll definitely do
something all right so what did he say
brazil's president jeff bolsonaro who
once threatened to pull out of the paris
accord said he would move up the
country's net zero target by a decade
to 2015
and end illegal deforestation by 2030.
earlier this month catholic
organizations pressured the brazilian
government to stop deforestation
in the amazon
now martin
listen to the sentence again
and to end illegal deforestation
by
if it's illegal
why not end it now
why do you have to wait
another decade in order to stop illegal
deforestation
so this whole thing is very interesting
to me so all of the top players the
countries are involved
and they're all going to play this tune
this was the meeting organized by joe
biden right now we've looked apart in
the past that the models
and we see that all of this actually is
based on a model
that isn't reflected in reality
at all correct and what's also
interesting for me is the the power that
the catholic
organizations
have in the the say that they have yes
so what is the agenda of the papacy
that is the ultimate question correct
so let's just look at the agenda again i
know that we have spoken about these
things many many times but this is just
a recap of where we are in the stream of
time correct
and this agenda is going to be carried
forward whether we like it or not yeah
and basically
the bible is saying
that these events would take place on
earth
and they are just giving their side of
the story
but in actual fact there's another power
behind the scenes
pope francis like saint francis of
assisi talks about the universal
fraternity of humanity
and this not simply because we are
interconnected and related one to
another but it's also because we all
come together
as one species to praise god for the
great work of creation
so the church claims that humans are
responsible for looking after nature
this comes from genesis when that
creation god charged at them to tell and
to keep
this imperative for care also extends to
the teaching about resting on the
sabbath day
which is for human beings also to
preserve creation
indeed from the book of deuteronomy
related with the book of exodus
genesis
somebody has a sense of liberation has
the sense of giving respite and rest to
any other system any system that is that
is oppressed and that lives in bondage
and i was saying it's a great honor for
me to be asked to
say some words during this webinar
and because we're here to discuss
biodiversity and i suspect that most of
the people listening are human beings
maybe there's a few dogs and cats in
people's houses but let me bring the
voice of the wild to start off with
that's in chimpanzee hello this is me
jane
i did indeed spend many years studying
our closest living relatives we know now
that we share
98.6 of our dna with them
and
during that time i learned a great deal
we've got this one
beautiful green and blue planet planet
earth
created by god
how is it possible that the most
intellectual creature to ever walk on
this planet is destroying its only home
so martin
and there in a nutshell we had the
biodiversity issue
and we had the sabbath issue
and this was
what the purpose of the vatican was in
introducing this massive change
and i'm always intrigued when we hear
these stories that we share 96
of our genetic material
with the chimpanzee
and that is why we are related but in
the same sentence she says that god
created it right
i'm sure she is aware as a scientist
that we share 95 of the genes with a
mouse
so
you know we can throw around with
figures like that and just to make it
really ridiculous we share
more than 76 percent i believe of our
genes with a banana
so am i now directly related to a banana
because i
have 76 of those genes so why why
do you use all of this you know
the genetic system is such
that there are
all the structural genes which code for
proteins and
enzymes and all of those things
and they're the same the
metabolism
that takes place in protein production
in a banana is
is basically the metabolism that takes
place in protein production in any any
creature
so
to tout these figures
to make the point that we are related
and from an evolutionary background
is is uh totally counterproductive
in fact
the genes
that we should be watching are the
controlling genes
i always compare it to a piano
there is one set of keys
but how many tunes can you play yeah
so the way in which you select them and
the order in which you select them
determines the tune
so the fact that the blueprint is very
similar
but the way in which the tune is played
is totally dissimilar doesn't mean that
we are genetically
related god just used the blueprint to
create everything
that lives
but the biodiversity issue
is very important and as i said that'll
be
the next mega crisis that's not on the
radio radar yet so we have
just to recap we had the pandemic
then we'll have an economic crisis maybe
brought about by a
cyber crisis
then we'll have a climate crisis then we
will have a biodiversity
crisis and it will be linked on and say
this is the cause and it's linked to
creation
and creation is linked to the sabbath
like and this is where we're going right
cardinal turkson just mentioned that
that's what the cardinal said
so isn't it amazing that the bible talks
about
the mark of the beast
and let's just get it quite straight
right here
there are many voices that want to
define the mark of the beast
and we've answered this in many many
cases before but the mark of the beast
is very specific
because the beast
is a political religious entity
described in revelation chapter 13
and its criteria are identical to those
of the little horn
that is described in daniel chapter 7
and the criteria as listed one after the
other
when it would arise
how it would arise what kingdoms it
would remove when it arose
that it would persecute the saints that
it would change god's times and god's
laws that it would rule for a specific
period that it would have a mortal wound
in other words lose its political power
and regain it when the mortal wound is
healed and that it will instill its
mindset
upon the world
fits to one organization and one
organization alone and that is the paper
scene correct
and the reformers recognized it
and they said the little horn power in
daniel
is
a
description
of the papal power and they called that
power antichrist
and all the reformers were of the same
opinion
and the beast of revelation chapter 13
is a description of the papal power and
all the reformers accepted that and
wesley made no bones about it look at
wesley's description he says it is the
papal power
and we
concurring with all of those points
agree that it is the papal power
and this power the papal power has a
mark
and only
that power can define what its mark is
and it has stated categorically
that the mark of its
ecclesiastical power and the proof of
the fact that they have this
ecclesiastical power that it is above
the bible
is that they
move the solemnity
from the seventh-day sabbath to the
first day of the week which is sunday
and this is proof of the fact that they
stand above the bible
that is an arrogance
that is
incomprehensible it's an affront to god
it's an attack on the authority of god
because god said
i change not correct and jesus said
do not think that i've come to abolish
the law
so here is a definition of what the mark
is and at the council of laodicea
they
entrenched their ideology perhaps we
must do a whole
what's up on that we will they entrench
that ideology in their
legislation ex cathedral which means
they cannot change it without affecting
their infallibility
so the mark of the beast is not any day
the mark of the beast is their defined
sunday observance contrary and
forbidding the observance of the
seventh-day sabbath which they call the
jewish sabbath
although it originates in eden
so the mark of the beast
is what they are heading for and the
climate change
agenda is going to give them the tool
in order to do it let's be quite blatant
about it
now
we've dealt with this many times but
just to refresh the ideas let's go to
the horse's mouth and let them tell us
again
how they perceive these things and what
their agenda is right the reason i think
it's important that we do this
is to show we've just shown that the
paper c
is
part and parcel
with this whole great research every
single decision
and they've got a great influence
on how this will be playing out
you know martin i would like to
at the risk of being conspiratorial
say it's not only an influence
it is a directive power
it is a directive power through its
knights of malta
and jesuitical organizations
they are involved at every single level
whether it is religious political
economical
no matter what they are actually in
control
of the money purse
so let's have a look what america the
official jesuit magazine
in the united states has to say about
this issue
pope francis has just released his new
encyclical on the environment laudato c
first the big contribution of laudato c
is an overview of the environmental
crisis from a religious point of view
until now the dialogue about the
environment was framed mainly with
political scientific and economic
language now the language of faith
decisively enters the discussion
fourth against those who argue that a
papal encyclical on the environment has
no real authority pope francis
explicitly states that laudato sea is
now added to the body of the church's
social teaching it continues reflection
on modern day problems that began with
leah the 13th encyclical ray ram navaram
on capital and labor in 1891.
fifth discussions about ecology can be
grounded in the bible and church
tradition in chapter 2 pope francis
introduces the gospel of creation in
which he leads readers through the call
to care for creation that extends as far
back as the book of genesis when
humankind was called to till and keep
the earth
and finally this encyclical is addressed
to everyone on the planet and calls for
a new way of looking at things we face
an urgent crisis when the earth has
begun more and more to look like in pope
francis's vivid language an immense pile
of filth still the document is hopeful
reminding us that because god is with us
all of us can strive to change course we
can move towards an ecological
conversion in which we can listen to the
cry of the earth and the cry of the poor
to use religious language what the pope
is calling for is conversion
[Music]
now martin
this obviously links the whole scenario
to the religious world right
and the pub is calling for conversion
but don't we have a new definition of
conversion here correct conversion to
what
to the common good
conversion to the common good and the
climate agenda
but to me the bible
when it talks about conversion
is totally different right
doesn't it mean turning away from sin
yes 180 degree turn around in your life
and what is the definition of sin we
just did that yeah and do you think that
there is a reason why we did what sin is
i think that
it's very important that we understand
what sin is because
this power
has totally redefined sin according to
their common good agenda
so that is the real crux behind the
matter correct it is enforcing a mindset
that gives honor to the first piece yes
and the first beast has already made it
quite plain
that it has the authority
to dictate this morality
and the proof of the fact that they have
the power to dictate morality
is that
they authorized
the change from the sabbath to the
sunday which is a mark of their
ecclesiastical power and therefore by
acknowledging it you are acknowledging
them yes now
years ago
i gave lectures on
novarom
and the economic plan of the roman
catholic church
and we discussed it in one of the the
what's up where we spoke about
the book
uh ecclesiastical
megalomania yes
and what raram navaram really means it
is basically the communist socialist
agenda
in a form of fascism yes
which is the preferred
state that the vatican prescribes
so if we go to rerun
the encyclical of pope leo
the 13th on capital and labor we'll just
read this little portion here
it is this above all which is the reason
arid motive of sunday rest
a rest sanctioned by god's great law of
the ancient covenant
remember thou keep holy the sabbath day
and taught to the world by his own
mysterious rest after the creation of
man
he rested on the seventh day from all
his work which he had done
so here you have this misnomer
that sunday rest
is equated to the sabbath
but of course it is not
it is a law
according to the roman catholic church
based solely
on the authority
of the church
correct in fact
the roman catholic church has publicly
stated that you can read the bible
from genesis
to revelation and you will find not one
verse advocating the keeping of sunday
it is a law based on catholic authority
alone yes and this is what
that
one thing like you've mentioned over and
over
is what gives them their authority
correct if you adhere to this
you acknowledge that they are the
authoritative figure correct
and when the reformation
finally at the council of trent was
confronting the roman catholic system
and saying
that the authority should be based on
scripture sola scriptura the archbishop
of reggio
got up in that council
and said you protestants say that you
believe in sola scriptiira then why
don't you follow the bible why do you
keep sunday which is a law of the
catholic church
and ignore the authority of your
scripture
so you
are just rebels
and you have to get back into line
and had the reformation at that stage
taken the opportunity
and had they said
you know what you're right we should go
back to the authority of this word
and this word prescribes the keeping of
the seventh day sabbath
and not according to your law at the
council of laodicea the first day of the
week which is based on your tradition
and your authority alone
so you are saying
that the bible should be
regarded and studied in the light of
your tradition
they should have said no correct your
tradition should come in harmon into
harmony with the scripture because in
vain you worship me teaching for
doctrine the commandments of men
so here
they make no bones about it that sunday
rest is part of their labor and capital
yes
and this started with pope leo and like
we saw in the video just now la dao to
see
is based on a lot
that was said
and the jesuits themselves said that it
was basically a rehash yes of
novaram
adding the capital and labor issue in
other words the economy
to the morality
and that's where we're heading yes
that's the agenda
so if we go to the encyclical lodar to c
which we've dealt with many many times
let's just make sure that we
get the same message
we'll only read the highlighted portion
along these same lines rest on the
seventh day is meant not only for human
beings
but also so that your ox and your donkey
may have rest
the biblical tradition clearly shows
that this renewal entails recovering and
respecting
the rhythms inscribed in nature by the
hand of the creator we see this for
example in the law of the sabbath
on the seventh day god rested from all
his work
he commanded israel to set aside each
seventh day as a day of rest a
sabbath
and then he blows it right
exactly by continuing on sunday our
participation in the eucharist has
special importance
sunday like the jewish sabbath is meant
to be a day which heals our relationship
with god with ourselves with others and
with the world
sunday is the day of the resurrection
the first day of the new creation
whose first fruits of the lord's risen
humanity the pledge of the final
transfiguration of all created reality
it also proclaims man's eternal rest in
god in this way christian spirituality
incorporates the value of relaxation and
festivity
so now here he moves the solemnity from
the sabbath to the sunday yeah from the
first day of seventh day to the first
day correct
the law of weekly rest forbade work on
the seventh day so that your ox and your
donkey may have rest and the son of your
maidservant then the stranger may be
refreshed
rest opens our eyes to the larger
picture and gives us renewed sensitivity
to the rights of others
and so the day of rest centered in the
eucharist
martin what day is that he just said it
the sunday the sunday yes
sheds its light on the whole week and
motivates us to greater concern for
nature and the poor i don't know how he
gets that one but he links it to
creation right
now just linking it to the eucharist
and they want a common eucharist
they want a common eucharist with the
protestant world yes not even the
protestant they want it with all nations
we've shown in a video long ago
that the hindus
and all of them attend
masses
correct
now the eucharist of course
is a perpetual sacrifice one and the
same as the cross
which violates the biblical scripture
which says by one sacrifice he is
forever made perfect and then
embedded in it you have
transubstantiation
so that it becomes the literal body and
the sacrifice that was enacted on the
cross they say that the priest has the
power to create christ in this wafer
correct and since mass is being read all
over the world in different time zones
there is
not a second when there is not a mass
when christ is converted to a literal
body that basically negates christ
and makes him
basically a corpse to be consumed
by all humanity it is the greatest
affront against the one sacrifice
whereby he has forever made perfect
this is an antichrist system this is an
apostate system this is a system
that takes upon itself powers
that belong to god alone
i won't be surprised
if the future
laws that will be implemented will
have something to do
with forced or
coercion into
a common eucharist common eucharist
well they've been pushing that in the
in the economical movement for many many
years
so
we have the sunday
and we have the negation
basically of the one sacrifice whereby
christ has made perfect
now martin the papacy is planning
and has planned meetings
with a number of role players
and from the medical world there's fauci
for example
but i'm fascinated
at the type of people
that are being invited to
take part in these summits
so you have rock stars
with
very
questionable ideas
that they put out there into the world
you have pro-abortion people and you
have anti-abortion people
and we've already said
in a previous one
that the papacy is well geared to absorb
any ideology as long as it is not based
on the scriptures
so
we said that it is willing to absorb and
capable of absorbing those that want to
be saved by their works and those that
want to be saved in their sins
it's amazing that they don't address the
sins
of some of the individuals which
they
employ in their activities
but they do address anyone who wants to
stand on the scriptures and the
scriptures alone so let's just look at
this for completeness and then we'll
wrap it up
the vatican pontifical council for
culture and the kuda foundation are
organizing their fifth international
conference from may 6th to 8th the theme
this year is exploring the mind body and
soul
speakers will include anthony fauci
chelsea clinton jane goodall joe perry
and researchers from distinguished
universities like duke mit harvard and
notre dame among others the conference
will conclude with a message from pope
francis the event is usually held at the
vatican in 2018 participants attended an
audience with pope francis this year the
three-day event will be held online
because of the pandemic like in previous
years leading physicians scientists
religious leaders policymakers and
philanthropists will discuss the latest
breakthroughs in medicine healthcare
delivery and prevention and to the
cultural impact of technological
advances it will also discuss how to
make quality healthcare available and
affordable
before we sum that up
it's interesting
that they have that picture
which is of course the very famous one
where god and humanity are touching but
they're wearing medical gloves again
their form of the health message is
always linked to their message
because that's how you keep people
captivated
they have fear of of diseases
and the great savior
is the system
which they have created
whereas god has given a health message
to his people and he has promised
none of the diseases
with which the egyptians
were plagued
shall be upon you
if
you follow
my
health directives
so
the vatican is planning
this meeting and they're calling fauci
chelsea clinton pfizer
ceo
pigtech oligarchs at health conference
exploring the mind body and soul you see
we're linking religion and uh and health
and health and everything
how innovation and novel delivery
systems improve human health
the speakers include prominent and
diverse names such as the ceos of pfizer
moderna the director of the national
institute of health francis collins the
head of google health david feinberg dr
anthony fauci
also speaking at the conference will be
the united nations representative and
conservationist jane goodall
new age activist deepak chopra rock
guitarist joe perry mormon elder william
k jackson executive chair of the british
board of scholars and imam shike dr asim
yusuf model cindy crawford it's quite a
collection
it's amazing so
just this should tell you
that
it's not a no uh just to get together no
this is not a friendly get together this
is an agenda
and to anyone who denies that there is
an agenda i can only say
please wake up from your ostrich
theology and just wake up to what's
happening in the world
topics for the conference range from are
we what we eat
now it's interesting martin
that even on the level of eating there's
a counterfeit correct
there is a new age agenda
and there is a biblical agenda and
what's on the table might be the same
you know what's interesting
when i was involved in the occult
world
the high occult tests
they would go on to vegetarian diets
and they believed that this was
essential for their spirituality
and people that were steeped
in occultism were often
vegetarians
adolf hitler
was steeped in occultism
but he was a vegetarian
so in the new age movement and in all of
these movements if you want to have a
spiritual enlightenment clear a clear
mind then you would move in that
direction
now that doesn't mean that the
vegetarianism is wrong no
because god also wants you to have a
clear mind and he's given you this kind
of thinking but if you are steeped in
the new age
then
that which is in itself good is used for
a wrong purpose so you have to be very
careful
when you make a study of these things
and then of course they're going to
discuss human enhancement do you think
you can improve on god's very good
well we've shown
previously that there's a lot of and
klaus schwab also said this
human implant transhumanism then to
living healthily to 120 and beyond
it's interesting that many of the
prominent people in the world
regularly reach the hundreds right and
they are mostly vegetarians as well
but
some of them have very interesting
connections to masonry and occult
agendas
let's not go there
sustainable healthcare protecting our
environment religious dietary practices
and health
is there a counterfeit health message
definitely
there's a biblical one
and there's a counterfeit and it might
actually be close
right it might actually be close
like the devil works like that yes it's
always like it's like that we that you
said the difference between presumption
and faith it's a
breath it's a hair breath
this is fascinating to me
and how do you define the soul
revolutionizing of cell therapy as well
as comprehensive covet 19 solutions and
new generations of vaccines
so the more crises you have the more
medical intervention you have the more
dependent you become upon the health
system
i think it is time to practice the
health message
in god's way yes and in god's way there
is a component
which is prayer
you have to be in contact with god
so that the true god
can work through
the system and your obedience to health
in order to bring about the changes
because
only
god has life within himself
and god has implanted
the life factors into your system
and when he breathed into you the breath
of life then man
became a living soul not receive a
living soul
so pope francis will close the event by
giving the participants a private
virtual
audience
so normally the one
who closes the event and sums it all up
is the one who has the final say that's
what you say right
biden promises
once in a generation investment during
pitch for 2 trillion infrastructure and
climate plan
now martin
if you're going to build new build back
beta then you have to take away what
there was and build back better so here
we have an infrastructure plan
it's interesting to me
that
trump wanted to upgrade all the
facilities
but they want to build back
better
and there's quite a price track
president joe biden unveiled a roughly 2
trillion jobs
proposal focused on infrastructure and
the climate crisis in a speech in
pittsburgh on wednesday stressing his
support of labor unions
and his hope the investment would lift
the middle class
it's a once in a generation investment
in america unlike anything we've seen or
done since we built the
interstate highway system and the space
rates decades ago it's the largest
american jobs investment since world war
ii
it'll create millions of jobs good
paying jobs it'll grow the economy make
us more competitive around the world
promote our national security interests
and put us in a position to win the
global competition with china
in the upcoming years biden said
he says it will he grow the
economy but they will probably be a cr
have to be
some
casualties along the way absolutely
so harris is to lead the biden task
force promoting unions and labor
organizing president joe biden will sign
an executive order on monday that will
create a task force to promote labor
organizing
the wise house said
at a time when just over six percent of
u.s private sector workers belong to
unions
so basically what they want to do is
unionize the world correct now
martin
where did the unions
originate in roman catholicism
in the vatican in fact
i didn't put that article in but there's
an article where they
boast and say that
unions are still catholic they're linked
to the roman catholic church so can you
see that finger in every pie everybody
so when it came to rerum novarum and
capital and labor labor it was essential
to create the great labor unions and the
labor unions will be one of the means to
bring about a time of trouble such as
never was
because they will enforce the moral
agenda of rome
and what did we see linked to moral now
the climate change what is the dow to
see got in it sunday sunday the the
novorum also had sunday
so all of this is coming together so the
president and the vice president believe
that the decline of union membership
is contributing to serious societal and
economic problems in our country the
white house said in a fact sheet
if you want to go back
to an era of reaganism
and thatcherism
the great problem that these people had
was the labor unions so they started to
put pressure on the labor unions to get
rid of them
but that's contrary to the papal agenda
so
here we have the reverse taking place
yes just in time for this great reset
just in time and the labor union will
make sure
that every single person complies
correct
because if you don't do what they say
you could just
end up in pieces
correct correct
so let's just read these statements from
the spirit of prophecy again
we are now to use all our entrusted
capabilities in giving the last warning
message to the world
in this work we are to preserve our
individuality
we are not to unite with secret
societies or with trade unions
we are to stand free in god looking
constantly to christ for instruction at
every step
all our movements are to be made with
the realization of the importance of the
work to be accomplished for the lord
martin can you see that this is in
direct opposition to the trend in the
world
so is there an agenda yes or no
definitely if you can't i'm sorry if you
cannot see this now
then you have to
open your eyes absolutely
satanic agencies are becoming more
determined in their rebellion against
god the trade unions will be the cause
of the most terrible violence that has
ever been seen amongst human beings
now we've had a couple of examples of
that in our own environment i've had my
ribs broken
by trade union actions so i know what it
means to stand
on the other side of their wrath
i have looked into their eyes
and i've seen things in those eyes that
would scare you to death
if you didn't have god
because god is mightier
than all of these powers put together
i want to state it categorically
that i believe that the powers of evil
are working now such as never before in
human history
and the papal power is just what the
scripture said it was
it is the power
that aligns itself against the majesty
of heaven
and if you go along with the system
you will suffer their same consequences
therefore come out of her my people that
you receive not of her
play and that is not the easy route
the easy route will be to conform
so they will come together the churches
will come together they will have a
climate sunday
the culmination of the campaign will be
a national climate sunday event on
sunday the 5th of september 2021
to share church commitments and pray for
bold action and courageous leadership at
cop 26 climate sunday
has been organized by churches together
in britain and ireland
with the support from charities
christian aid tier fund
russia uk and operation noah
this is fascinating martin
is there an agenda definitely are we
heading in a direction yes have we been
singing this tune
we've known we've also never changed out
to no we don't change our tune because
they don't change theirs no
we cannot change our tune because our
tune
is directly from scripture
okay martin let's just look how they're
pushing the sunday issue
as christians we believe that the earth
is the lord's and everything in it
we are confident that god calls us to be
part of restoring all of creation to
full life
that's why this year as the uk prepares
to host the united nations climate
summit cop 26 churches across the uk are
getting ready to take action through
climate sunday
climate sunday is an initiative of the
uk church's environmental issues network
we're calling on churches all across the
country to get involved in taking action
for climate justice
so what does it involve
we're inviting churches to begin prayer
and worship our calling to climb action
begins with our faith hold the climate
service and together as a church family
begin to explore why action for the
climate is part of our
discipleship we're also inviting you to
commit to long-term action for creation
in this crucial year for our climate we
as churches can play our part in the
journey of our whole society towards
climate positive living discern the next
step for your church to take together
finally we're inviting you to speak up
the church can bring a distinctive voice
to the call for climate justice rooted
in our faith in a just and generous god
join with others in calling for our
leaders to be courageous at cop 26 and
to take ambitious action for creation
this is a year for our church to live
out our mission to love our neighbor and
to seek justice for all creation
how will you get involved
martin isn't it interesting that they
want all of these things
in place before the end of 2021
correct
the aiming for cop26
exactly road to cop26 eu bishops call
for nations to protect work free sunday
i mean the headlines are everywhere and
we don't have to read it
but i also find it very interesting
that this debate is in the echelons of
political power as well
so here we have an interesting
discussion
in uh the house where schumer
is taking the position that why can't we
do things on sunday
and somebody answers him
and gets it wrong but nevertheless it's
interesting let's listen to this
[Music]
where republicans recently passed a bill
to eliminate early voting on sunday on
sunday
a day when many church-going
african-americans participate in voter
drives known as souls to the polls
what an astonishing coincidence
outlaw vote putting on a day when
african-american churches sponsor get
out the vote efforts
i'd like one of the republican members
on this committee
to give us a plain sense justification
for that restriction i cannot speak for
georgia but i can speak for mississippi
on why we would never do that on a
sunday or hold an election on a sunday
you know this is our currency this is a
dollar bill
this says the united states of america
in god we trust
etched in stone
in the u.s
senate chamber is in god we trust when
you swore in all of these witnesses the
last thing you said to them and your
instructions was so help you god
in god's word in exodus 20 18 it says
remember the sabbath and keep it holy
so that is my response to senator
schumer
martin she's got the day wrong
she's confused the sunday with the
seventh day
but i find it interesting that she was
so prepared
for an apparently impromptu question
because she had the note ready she had
the verse ready she had everything ready
sometimes i wonder if these things are
scripted
well it's always interesting to watch
these things huh yes it's interesting
especially if you take all of what we've
just done in into consideration and i
mean these videos go out into the world
so is this implanting an idea well
there's a lot of people that actually
feel the same way that she's just
mentioned exactly so is the thesis
antithesis is this hegelian dialectic or
is it pure coincidence you know
everything in this world some say is
pure coincidence
all right let's wrap this up martin
matthew 5 18 for verily i say unto you
till heaven and earth pass one jot or
one tittle shall in no wise pass from
the law
till all be fulfilled
and in hebrews 13 verse 8 we read jesus
christ the same yesterday and today and
forever malakai 3 verse 6 for i am the
lord i change not
martin
did god change the sabbath day
no
did he change the law no
did he change his mind no
because he cannot change
so is it evident that the papacy
is claiming authority above god by
changing the day definitely and stating
so publicly
and reprimanding protestants
by using this power openly
and getting the whole world
financial
you name it we've just shown it
on board
and we're heading in a direction so our
question
where's this going cop 26
and why is the agenda so urgent
is it because the time is short
and they know it
let's pray
heavenly
father
we have said all along there's an agenda
and there's an agenda behind the agenda
and there are puppeteers
and they are singing the same tune
and they are using their propaganda
machine
to create a similar mindset in
all of humanity
and anyone who dares to contravene or
contradict
what they are saying
is an enemy
of the common good
heavenly father
help us to be individuals
that make individual choices
based on your word
is my prayer in jesus name
amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video
click here
thank you and we'll see you again